hi this is for my baby friends but if  you're not a gay B you're more than  welcome to say we're inclusive here I'm  sitting here in my closet thinking of  you stranger and knowing that some of  you might be setting a resolution to  come out this year would it make it  easier if you had someone to practice  with I'm happy to be your practice  person I'll go live at two o'clock  Central Time on New Year's Day if you  want to practice coming out to me I'm  here and I welcome you if you want to  ask me anything else you can do that too  see you on New Year's  I don't know exactly what's going on  here this is an old woman in a closet  talking to her gabies and offering to  let them practice coming out to her this  is a  imagine this is your grandmother where's  Grandma she's in the closet shooting  another Tick-Tock video  [Music]